eccoci qui mi chiamo serena cibi schino
e sono sì o amministratore delegato di
un brand di moda italiano ma mi piace
pensare a me stessa come direttore
artistico del mio brand
e a voi care ragazze e cari ragazzi che
voglio raccontare questa mia storia
facciamo che oggi vi porto con me in
viaggio useremo un mezzo a mia misura
ecco a voi tutti partiamo da qui da
torino data 1970 torino italia scuola
parini elementare quella bambina
all'interno del cerchio rosso sono io da
bambina sognavo di fare la veterinaria
amavo tantissimo gli animali soprattutto
i cani per cui dopo il liceo classico
iscrizione a veterinaria la facoltà di
veterinaria
ma nel 1991
colpo di scena chiamo rapporto papà e
mamma e comuni coloro che avevo deciso
di interrompere gli studi di veterinaria
che nella vita non avrei voluto fare la
veterinaria e non sapevo che cosa volevo
fare nella mia vita non la veterinaria e
vi lascio solo immaginare la delusione
dopo tutti quegli anni inizia critici i
miei e dei miei genitori
delusione e passatemi il francesismo
incazzatura dei miei genitori che cosa
volevo fare
volevo fare un'esperienza all'estero
partire e andare imparare la lingua
inglese
allora avevo studiato francese vicinanza
della francia avanti savoia quindi
decido di partire per gli stati uniti
per boston bene seconda tappa 1992
boston 26
non sapevo una parola di inglese
giravo per tutto a posto con un
vocabolario tascabile in tasca
vi ricordo che allora non esisteva
google traduttore o perlomeno era agli
studenti non era concesso avere
cellulari costavano troppo per
mantenermi vado a fare la cameriera in
un ristorante è chiaramente italiano e
attraverso le mance riuscivo a diciamo
arrivare a fine mese mi iscrivo a un
corso di business administration
una bellissima esperienza ho incontrato
studenti da tutto il mondo
che cosa ho imparato ho imparato che un
biglietto da visita si riceve e si porge
rigorosamente con le due mani né nel
mondo asiatico è un sorriso in asia può
nascondere non solo felicità ma può
nascondere un imbarazzo
ho imparato anche marketing il customer
satisfaction
il cliente ha sempre ragione delle
grandi lezioni ma a boston
una grandissima esperienza è stato
lavorare all'interno iniziare un
percorso all'interno di una boutique di
un famoso stilista americano come
commessa ma ho avuto durante una
riunione all'interno dell'azienda
l'opportunità di fare una proposta per
il lancio di un nuovo brand eco
sostenibile indirizzato a i giovani
universitari è piaciuto il mio progetto
e la mia proposta mi è stato dato uno
spazio e ho iniziato questo bellissimo
percorso all'interno di questo progetto
del lancio di un giovane marchio ora
data 1994 tappa udine italia come
riassumere questa tappa in una parola
va dove ti porta il cuore
non me ne voglia susanna tamaro mi sono
trovata di fronte ad una scelta di vita
importante rimanere a boston è fare un
progetto fanno un lavoro che mi piaceva
tantissimo o andare a udine dove mi
portava l'amore mio cuore
quindi parto per udine e a udine non
avevo opportunità lavorative nell'ambito
del fashion della moda non c'erano
giovani brand per cui dovendo lavorare
mi reinvento agente di viaggio il
viaggio è sempre stata una mia passione
per cui porto a casa cataloghi studio
organizza viaggi per i miei clienti su
misura ed ecco a voi
secondo colpo di scena nel 1998
leggo sul giornale esce un bando della
regione friuli venezia giulia dove
veniva data un'opportunità a donne e
giovani donne
un'opportunità tutto al femminile di
proporre un'idea imprenditoriale
originale e di discutere questa idea
imprenditoriale
chi avesse passato il colloquio avrebbe
potuto sostenere questo corso dove degli
esperti che avrebbero aiutato a stendere
il tuo business plan quindi iniziare
questa startup la regione metteva a
disposizione anche dei fondi regionali
per aiutare
l'apertura del tuo business quindi vengo
scelta tra venti donne imprenditrici
imprenditrici e gennaio 99 a problemi
azienda di abbigliamento a udine bene
quarta tappa data 2003
parigi francia il titolo di questa tappa
think global ho deciso che volevo
vendere decido che volevo vendere il mio
brand anche all'estero per cui quale
fiera nella moda a livello
internazionale
poteva darmi questa opportunità
parigi atmosfera de paris era questa
fiera per giovani designer ma per
entrare e avere l'opportunità di fare
questa fiera parigi
occorreva passare una selezione dove
venivano visionate i tuoi capi di
abbigliamento il tuo lavoro per poi
accedere alla fiera fiera che c'è
tuttora e si chiama who's next e che
faccio tutt'ora un parto per parigi con
la valigia i capi hotel super chip volo
super chic di fronte alla commissione
presenti nei capi e venga accettata una
grandissima soddisfazione per cui inizio
è il percorso di atmosfere fantastico
perché mi trovo piccolo stand in mezzo a
big della moda a grandi aziende da cui
imparare tantissimo e una sfida
meravigliosa clienti che arrivavano da
tutto il mondo e che entravano nel tuo
stand per cui io arrivavo stiravo i capi
apprendevo facevo il visual vendevo
era bellissimo bellissimo l'esperienza
di boston molto utile ecco che clienti
giapponesi il biglietto veniva dato con
le due mani ne ha ricevuto con le due
mani per cui un confronto internazionale
importantissimo per me quinta tappa data
2013 contea di kilifi kenya africa
ed eccoci lì e il 2013 e siamo in kenya
a kilifi col mio gruppo stile il viaggio
tema collezione per prendere ispirazione
del paese ed è nel 2013 in africa che
abbiamo conosciuto queste piccole
comunità di artigiani nei vari villaggi
della contea di kilifi e con loro
abbiamo creato un sistema di laboratori
ognuno con le proprie specificità
ma una cosa importante per me abbiamo li
abbiamo resi indipendenti
abbiamo dato loro l'opportunità di fare
un lavoro attraverso dei timing
attraverso dei risultati
un progetto è far sì che loro siano
indipendenti economicamente per cui il
loro villaggio villaggio possa crescere
le loro famiglie i loro figli possono
iniziare andare a scuola e iniziare
anche un percorso di scolarizzazione
importante in africa noi con loro ancora
oggi creiamo degli accessori
noi mettiamo la nostra creatività tipica
italiana e loro portano la loro
incredibile capacità il loro incredibile
e innato senso del colore
questa esperienza è stata messa a dura
prova con la p e 21 con la primavera è
stato 2021 durante il periodo di lock
d'animo abbiamo voluto io il mio gruppo
di lavoro mantenere lo stesso questo
progetto per cui le ragazze le giovani
ragazze che fanno parte del mio team in
un call whatsapp ogni giorno sentivano
gli artigiani e hanno mandato avanti
tutto il progetto noi l'abbiamo portato
a casa loro l'hanno portata a casa sono
state bravissime e sono la parte loro
costituiscono la parte diciamo colmano
tutto quello che la mia il mio totale
ignoranza nei social media è in tutti
questi mezzi che io ritengo non
sottovaluto ritengo che siano
fondamentali nell'ambito lavorativo
importantissimi ma non mi appartengono
per cui grazie ragazze oggi il kenya e
luogo dei miei progetti più belli degli
incontri con persone che hanno cambiato
definitivamente il mio sguardo sul mondo
e il senso del mio lavoro alla
conclusione di questo percorso di questo
viaggio strano viaggio
permettetemi di di disegnare un cerchio
intorno a tutta questa tutte queste
esperienze che ho raccontato e ai luoghi
che abbiamo mappato in questo cerchio si
chiama perseveranza che è il contrario
di tutto e subito
ecco così il signor treccani che la sa
lunga definisce nel suo vocabolario il
verbo perseverare perseverare dal latino
per severus oltremodo severe
rigoroso e viene definito come
persistere mantenersi fermo e costante
nei propositi nelle azioni nello
svolgimento di un'attività o di
un'impresa mi piace pensare che in
questa parola potente e bellissima si
era chiusa tutta la mia esperienza di
imprenditrice perseveranza nel colore a
tutti i costi anche quando la moda
andava in una direzione diversa
perseveranza nell'idea che il cliente è
al centro di tutto il nostro lavoro
sempre e perseveranza nel nostro
meraviglioso progetto in africa
perseveranza per me significa fare ogni
giorno la tua parte la tua piccola parte
con chiaramente tanta passione e
dedizione e non dimentichiamoci i sogni
che sono importantissimi e adesso cosa
si fa
care ragazze e cari ragazzi ripartiamo
insieme da qui grazie
[Applauso]